il ya donc deux niveaux élevés comme
gratuit concurrents il ya il ya des
stars de la chanson regarder quels sont
les concurrents notamment ya emmanuel
moire way au non évènement
j m a dit voilà
c'est pas normal
chimène badi aussi bien c'est une banque
qui pourrait plaire à leur dédiant
[Musique]
il ya le grand favori un sébile alassane
ba oui cette année
[Musique]
alors dieu cay 1 il ya un classement
d'équipé par les fans il est très très
très loin devant bias est de 3 700
milles selon le terme de vue que sur son
compte youtube il est déjà plus de 2
milliards en mai pour 50000 habitants
soit là c'est ça qui vous allez voir et
vous allez découvrir j'en suis sûr qu
encore une fois les réseaux sociaux ce
n'est pas la france pour arrêter de
penser ça c'est un tout petit milieu qui
qui qui s'autoalimente et même s'il est
très fort sur les réseaux youtube et
tout ça je pense que c'est pas lui qui
sera en tête
à mon avis ça va être chimène badi free
a dit mes raisons contraires les gens
qui veulent dans la fantaisie dans votre
très concret moi perso vraiment je
l'adoré c'est la première des séries et
beaucoup de talent je suis assez h
taximen je trouve aujourd'hui table mais
voilà qui à chaque semaine mais les
raisons et les réseaux sociaux ne font
pas tout dernière les andro était très
populaire sur la réparation et pourtant
c'était tout ça c'est fait la moue
j'avais su que personne ne connaissait
le public ne vote pas alors fils le
principe le principe de l'émission
gilles ce qu'en fait il ya pendante il
ya trois directs et alitalia demi finale
demi finale et une finale
après nokia vrai bon c'est un peu tendu
mais le jury donnera un avis ils sont
pas là n'ont rien il n'y a pas de vote
du jury
en revanche le public va choisir a
envoyé des notes de à 12 comme leur
vision explique art le plus de points se
qualifie d'abord pour la finale et on
tuera un grand vainqueur qui partira à
l'eurovision peut-être pour pour
remporter la coupe qu'on a quand même
pas eu souvent depuis m'arrivée
adversaire numéro un de son pays ouais
je pressens un fiasco pour deux raisons
le tpn quand vous perdez
quand vous perdez amir vous perdez tout
rien plus rien c'était le porte étendard
c'est lui qui nous avait si bien
représenté ballmer chaque année c'est
lui c'est lui qui manageait le jury mais
sans lui il ya plus de jury deuxième
chose je respecte tous les artistes
vraiment mais on ne sait pas ce que
c'est est ce que ce sont des espoirs des
artistes sur le retour des valeurs
confirmées un peu c'est quoi ce concours
on ne sait pas alors là c'est pas la
première fois que france télé temps un
concours pour trouver la perle rare pour
l'horizon en 2006 michel drucker avait
présenté un show qui s'appelait et si
c'était vous vous rappelez omar ça n'a
pas marché c'est qu'ils avaient produit
c'est trop macadam histoire
alors les produits un truc un marché
doit alors ça m'est arrivé à niasse ya
fort longtemps c'était longtemps non je
suis très honnête en fait ce que j'ai
produit globalement on n'a pas
fonctionné alain à la différence de ce
que j'ai animé qui est souvent plus tôt
marché on va dire ça aurait gentil alors
juste les français à l'eurovision on en
a les classements 2009 patricia kaas des
huitièmes oui en 2010 jessy matador 12e
amaury vassili 15e en bonne alors déjà
2018 22e sais c'est pas terrible non un
modèle bourgeois 23e pour la 26ème et
des andes génie 25e
amir le mieux on l'a dit c'était et moi
je la préfère qu'il soit bon enfant
[Musique]
c'est alors que marco est quand même qui
à chaque fois il ya un petit bout des
anglais quand même mais bien sûr bluff
classe m c'est pas normal je trouve pas
beaucoup la france et j'aurai moi j'aime
bien dans votre chanson j'adore parce
qu'elle est que 100 % française et
franchement j'ai adoré et je trouve pas
ça normal de mélanger des gens connus
parce qu'ils partent avec une avance par
rapport à vous c'est alors que mes fans
déjà l'esprit dit il est connu il est
choqué avec une météo gilad sharon
notamment en alsace
oui mais reconnaît que des gourmets ne
badine gmail mois il a pas eu la même
promo est mon coup de coeur de cette
année joue il dit mon pauvre
[Rires]